[Music]
hello everyone I want to start by
thanking my parents for watching this
from halfway around the world I have a
small message for them I met Bubba this
is a severe room week of arsons and I
hope mom's not crying well they're
mostly students here so I want to thank
my teachers I wanted like ever Lois for
always supporting me my unconventional
pursuits and I want to thank John
Brennan for introducing me to worship
production I would not be here without
him and I want to thank my amazing
collaborators none of them had any time
to work on this project but somehow
we're here I guess that's the magic of
filmmaking
I want to thank Nick Lane for giving
voice to the story
I want to thank Raphael d'argent and
Federico Torre and Mathias Coppins
for the amazing score and I want to
thank arnesto Sandoval for always being
there I want to thank imaging for
technical and emotional support and I
want to thank NIMH for her one-of-a-kind
accent and thank you to all my friends
who didn't help me on the film but
they're here thank you for being here I
love you all and of course I cannot get
off the stage without thanking the
Academy for this recognition it's it's
been an incredible week and as students
getting out into the real world we are
faced with uncertainty and this award
that means that maybe we are doing
something right it's incredibly
meaningful so I want to thank the
Academy think the governance the
officers the Executive Board everyone
that made is possible thank you
[Applause]